because these are this is what our
clubhouse another notification from
clubhouse
what's going on now a clubhouse let's
see what's going uh
clubhouse now uh
mark zuckerberg is doing a room with
lindy england
uh the uh remember the cigarette girl
from abu ghraib
that should be interesting remember the
one who was
sun clubhouse mark zuckerberg
lindy england from abu ghraib are doing
a room on
clubhouse
she's me and ray's favorite go-to joke
reference because most people have no
idea who she is
she's the girl that posed with the
cigarette
[Laughter]
that would be great if that was your
avatar on clubhouse
i'm gonna do a room after this on
clubhouse how to be a cancer influencer
just because you're terminally ill
doesn't mean you can't build a brand
how to be a cancer influencer i did
something else i did uh how to build
your brand while you're incarcerated
prison influencer it's so important
you know those are rooms at clubhouse
and people just just just
just talk and whine all day
because there's also there's smart
people that are whatever doing whatever
the hell they're doing inside of
training probably
and then there's everyone else who's
just whining you know there's not enough
representation in this
fake conversation they're having
they're like uh we don't have enough
women of color here in this
room about uh whatever it is you know
they're like you know like you you'll go
on clubhouse and it'll be like
uh hi we're we're starting a room
to just try to address the lack of uh
uh indigenous music producers
and we're just trying to
we found that there's there's not a lot
of native american
producing trap music
so we're bringing on and then all these
people are terrified like because real
people get on
and they're like tariff they have to be
like she'll bring in like a big dj and
have to be like
yeah yeah i ah
that bothers me too he's all coked out
in miami he's like
what is this people don't even know they
get into a clubhouse room they don't
even know what's going on there's like a
thousand people listening what they say
they think they're talking to their
friends it's some coked out
dj miami's he's talking to his friend
all of a sudden it's like no uh
what's her name uh my buddy from the new
york times who never mentions me
taylor laurence she's watching
she just tweeted someone said [ __ ] on
clubhouse because somebody said the r
word on clubhouse
and nobody uh nobody corrected them
jesus and i forget who it was it was one
of these big finance guys
they get on there thinking it's their
friends they're like can you believe
these retards
and then there's a thousand people there
listening to it
and some of them are journalists they're
just trying to screenshot they're trying
to like screen record or whatever
right jesus
who's she dropping a dime on don't say
the names i don't want to be a rat too
let me see some guy who follows me on
twitter i don't know what he does
she's dropping a dime on him because he
said the r word
i don't know what that means i i imagine
it means
a not nice word for the disabled
let's see
you know what you know what's funny
about these people too they also will
then
snitch on people and then delete it did
she delete it she might have let me see
can you imagine that just hanging out
clubhouse room snitching
like i hope i hope we get the co-founder
of tinder
saying something inappropriate
cause i'm a journalist
someone named felicia who who even is
felicia i don't know why what happened
well she was the one who said the r word
and then someone named mark also said it
or ben said it she's naming all these
people by the first name i don't even
know
is it a joke should we give her the
benefit of the doubt it's not a joke
maybe
no i don't think it is i don't think
it's a joke she's just ratting up
maybe she didn't understand the room the
clubhouse room that she went in was
called the [ __ ] room
where everyone gets to say the r word
and nobody rats
yeah she has like a time stamp for
youtube she's like at 405 you can hear
ben say alex maybe you could take us
through the
[ __ ] revolution i hope everyone who
used this word can think more carefully
about why people in the audience were
upset
how about everybody in the audience gets
off the app and goes and gets a job
because you know why i'll tell you why
you should have kept your mouth
shut god
everyone in the audience is upset you're
listening to someone's conversation
that's a weird thing about clubhouse
it's like
you're listening to a conversation of
people that would never even
acknowledge your existence on earth
that's how they
talk i just wow that echoed
i could throw me out of this area pretty
soon but this is how they [ __ ] talk
these people
don't you want to hear them speak when
you take a safari you don't want to see
the cheetahs eating
dinner with a tablecloth you want to see
them
tearing apart other animals because
that's how they live
so why would you want these tech bros to
be like well i
actually believe that no let them speak
how they speak when they're on some
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bike ride in silicon valley
they're thrown around
much worse than the r word
the tech bro such an interesting
creature yo bro
bro you gotta roast somebody you gotta
yo let's
trash somebody you gotta roast you gotta
roast somebody you're a comedian
oh i got an app
it's like it's like instagram but just
for pictures of clips
you know what's funny about this too is
she deleted her original tweet
where she accused someone of saying the
r word and then someone who was in the
room corrected her
and then so then she deleted that and
said it was actually this person so she
was slandering somebody
then deleted it and then said it was
actually this person i mean it's just
well she's a journalist
ben she's a great journalist and it's a
great profession of journalists we have
in this country
you should have kept your mouth shut
it's a great profession of journalists
sitting around on clubhouse trying to
catch tech bros being
inappropriate how about reporting on the
hell
world they've created about how about
you do a little research to dark money
where it's coming from
are you worried if that you do that
somebody throw you out of a plane
trying to catch people saying the armor
could anything be less important in this
[ __ ] nightmare world right now than
who said the r word on clubhouse
we can't get medicine to sick people
we should just give everyone health care
and before they get it call them a
[ __ ]
you think they would care do you think
they would care
hey you could go to the doctor [ __ ]
you'd be like thank you
thanks a lot